la présidente Myriam lesinatrices
messieurs les sénateurs je crois que
depuis 10 ans rarement cette audition
n'est aussi bien tombée et je veux vous
remercier de cette invitation en effet
lorsque l'on dirige une entreprise
publique et qu'on a déjà été trois fois
confronté pour son processus de
nomination à votre commission car cela a
été mon cas il est très important pour
nous de vous rendre compte et c'est tout
l'objet de mon attitude vis-à-vis de
vous aujourd'hui
je dois dire que en juillet dernier en
juillet 2022 quand nous avons pris la
décision de changer la lettre rouge
j'étais totalement conscient de toucher
à un objet totémique de la République et
complètement conscient des difficultés
de communication des critiques qui
arriveraient de ce point de vue je n'ai
pas été déçu
par contre et je vous le dis sincèrement
j'ai été très surpris de la polémique
sur le six jours sur 7 et sur le passage
quotidien du facteur pour une raison
simple c'est qu'il est faux c'est un
mensonge de dire que le facteur ne passe
plus tous les jours et que nous allons
remettre en cause le séjour sur 7 et je
le trouve
la première chose c'est que bien sûr
s'il y a trois fois moins de lettres 6
milliards contre 18 milliards en 2008 le
facteur s'arrête moins souvent mais par
rapport à votre très bon questionnement
madame la Présidente si je peux me
permettre chaque fois qu'il y a soit une
lettre à date soit un journal soit un
colis soigne l'être recommandée soit la
distribution d'un médicament soit la
distribution d'un repas le facteur
s'arrête il s'arrête et toute notre
stratégie et pardon de radoter car là je
vous l'ai répété à plusieurs reprises
c'est le six jours sur tête quotidien
sur la totalité du territoire et j'ai un
souvenir très précis je ne veux pas
désigner là c'est la triste qui m'a posé
en 2013 lors de mon premier passage
devant vous la question du passage du
dimanche je n'y ai pas vu un piège et
j'avais répondu ce que je vous réponds à
nouveau s'il faut passer le dimanche
parce qu'il y a un besoin de la
population nous passerons le dimanche
dans des conditions particulières au
travail le dimanche et nous trouverons
les volontaires par centaines de
facteurs qui seront prêts à ménager leur
travail donc la Poste traite attachée
aux 6 jours sur 7 c'est le cœur de sa
stratégie je vais vous le montrer elle
s'arrête partout quand il y a un objet à
distribuer comme le chauffeur de bus
s'arrête quand quelqu'un veut descendre
ou que quelqu'un veut monter par contre
si personne ne veut descendre et
personne ne veut monter le chauffeur de
bus ne s'arrête pas sauf pose technique
indispensable lié à sa biologie d'accord
c'est la même chose pour nous il n'y a
donc notre volonté je vais être encore
plus précis par rapport aux questions
posées excentées notre volonté c'est de
continuer six jours sur 7 on fait pas
cinq jours sur 7 comme les Britanniques
les Portugais les norvégiens 6 jours sur
7 et passer partout sur le territoire il
y a une chose qui est très
impressionnant en 2008 quand il y avait
18 milliards de lettres le facteur
livret 80% des points de distribution
sur le territoire donc il s'arrêtait pas
devant 100% des blocs ou les adresses
80%. là aujourd'hui c'est
48%. s'il y a moins de lettres il y a
moins d'arrêt mais notre stratégie c'est
de nous arrêter je dis le plus souvent
possible et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne renonçons pas aussi
jours sur 7 et nous ne renonçons pas au
passage quotidien c'est la raison d'être
de toute notre stratégie pourquoi parce
que nous avons rajouté à la lettre dont
le volume est en pleine attrition du
colis
des visites de liens social par exemple
dans la Mayenne nous avons passé un
accord avec le Conseil départemental de
la Mayenne présidé par Olivier richoud
où les facteurs avec la DMR font les
fameux visites de convivialité sociale
que vous avez décidé vous-même dans le
PLF SS 2023 sur l'appât donc la Poste va
garder le six jours sur 7 j'ai
l'impression la dette un peu lourd mais
je pense qu'il faut l'être la Poste va
garder le six jours sur 7 c'est le cœur
de sa stratégie et ce qu'elle cherche
c'est à s'arrêter le plus souvent
possible parce que plus elle s'arrête
plus ça veut dire qu'elle nourrit les
tournées de ces facteurs et plus elle
nourrit les tournées de ses facteurs
plus elle protège l'emploi des facteurs
c'est ma responsabilité de patron et
donc nous allons continuer à le faire de
ce point de vue et j'y reviendrai
j'invite tous les élus que vous êtes à
favoriser les
volumes d'affaires que les facteurs
peuvent apporter en plus de la lettre
car l'avenir de nos emplois de facteurs
ne va pas passer par la lettre c'est ça
que je partage avec vous enfin car cette
question m'a été posée par un sénateur
la poste n'a aucune intention de
remettre en cause les quartiers lettres
de nos facteurs qu'est-ce que c'est un
quartier lettres c'est que le facteur a
une tournée dans un village ou dans une
ville c'est la sienne il la connaît par
cœur il connaît tout le monde en ce
moment même et je n'ai pas peur de
l'avouer nous avons une baisse de la
qualité qui est liée au fait que le
nombre d'intérimaires est très important
depuis deux ans et demi pourquoi et bien
simplement parce que la covid a frappé
les facteurs comme tout le monde et que
quand on a des milliers de malades on ne
remplace pas les malades par des CDI on
les remplace par des intérimaires dès
l'année 2023 avec le reflux de la
pandémie nous allons très sensiblement
parle de milliers réduire le nombre des
intérimaires
et pourquoi est-il si important de
garder les quartiers lettres c'est que
les facteurs ils sont attachés et
surtout les clients et donc vous y êtes
très attaché on a sa factrice et son
facteur c'est la base du six jours sur 7
et du passage quotidien et je dois dire
que cette polémique m'a surprises
d'autant que dans son rapport et je veux
le souligner le sénateur chaise
accompagné de deux autres sénateurs
avaient lui-même théoriser le fait que
le timbre rouge n'était pas soutenable
pour la poste et après avoir réaffirmé
que nous voulons passer tous les jours
six jours sur 7 et que nous sommes à la
recherche de nouveaux plus pour nourrir
les tournées de nos facteurs je veux en
venir au fameux timbre rouge
le timbre rouge en fait sa disparition
sera cité comme un fait historique parce
qu'elle nous concerne tous mais
maintenant parlons des chiffres il faut
y revenir quand on est dans une
entreprise et de ce point de vue le
rapport de votre commission nous fournit
tous les éléments
il y avait en 2008
4,25 milliards de lettres rouges
échangées par an dans notre pays 4,25
milliards l'année dernière
275 millions dont 75 millions de lettres
rouges envoyés par les ménages il y a 30
millions de ménages en France vous
faites vite le calcul de l'être rouge et
demi par ménage et par an qu'est-ce que
ça signifie ça signifie que les millions
de Français n'ont pas n'aime plus le
timbre rouge mais pour les besoins
d'urgence on trouvait d'autres modes de
communication et le pire si on était
resté à 275 millions je crois que nous
n'aurions pas bougé c'est le pire c'est
que ça baisse de 80 par an c'est à dire
que en 2022 il y en a eu 275 et qu'il y
en avait plus de 380 millions en 2021
faites le calcul dans quatre ans il y en
a plus du tout et quand vous êtes chef
d'entreprise et que vous savez que dans
quatre ans il n'y en aura plus du tout
et bien la seule façon de faire de notre
point de vue c'est d'assumer ses
responsabilités en disant je vais
arrêter un service dont les Français ne
se servent plus que très marginalement
il y a bien sûr et madame la Présidente
merci d'avoir cité ce chiffre qui est
également dans votre rapport sénatorial
une économie considérable sur plusieurs
années c'était pointé par le rapport de
votre commission on parle de 500
millions d'euros ce qui me permet madame
la sénatrice puisqu'on en a parlé tout à
l'heure juste avant la séance de redire
que la suppression de la lettre rouge ne
sonne pas le glas du service public il
sauve le service public qui n'aura plus
500 millions à dépenser pour une lettre
qui n'est plus utilisée alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'il est aussi cher et bien
parce que la nuit nous prenions ces
lettres rouges nous les en voyons 300
tourner nationale genre Strasbourg
Bordeaux et dans trois avions qui ne
fonctionnaient que pour la lettre rouge
coup absolument considérable j'en viens
également parce que je sais que vous y
êtes très attentif à la dépense carbonée
ce très faible flux de l'être
représentait 25% de la dépense carbonée
du courrier et donc industriellement
j'assume et si j'avais à reprendre la
décision je la reprendrai d'avoir
proposé la fin de la lettre rouge qui
n'est plus utilisée et c'est l'un des
paradoxes et comme vous êtes des hommes
et des femmes politiques vous vivez dans
ce paradoxe les gens aiment la lettre
rouge il n'en écrivent plus comme mais
c'est la réalité
c'est la réalité c'est comme les marchés
ils aiment la lettre rouge il n'en
écrivent plus et le patron de
l'entreprise il prend la seule décision
nécessaire qui est d'arrêter de la
transporter alors ensuite dès lors qu'on
a franchi l'idée que industriellement il
fallait supprimer la lettre rouge la
question c'est comment on fait et je
veux vous parler très clairement du
choix qui était sur la table il y a deux
choix à ce moment là le premier choix
c'est de se tourner vers la population
en disant il y avait une lettre rouge
pour envoyer des nouvelles à J+1 il y en
a plus circuler il y en a il y a rien à
voir première solution je les considéré
deuxième solution dire que si vraiment
il y a un besoin absolument
urgent et que quelques ou quelqu'un
tient absolument à envoyer un message
pour le lendemain on a fabriqué la
lettre hybride là illettré rouge alors
elle est compliquée mais elle est
compliquée mais comme on a pu l'être
rouge on a inventé quelque chose qui
permet d'envoyer un message on me dit
alors et c'est exact ça introduit une
fracture numérique entre ceux qui vont
le faire sur leur smartphone et sur
internet sur laposte.fr et ceux qui ne
sont pas capables de le faire la Poste a
réponse à ça il faut à ce moment-là
prendre son courrier je prends
aller au bureau de poste le faire
scanner et il est et il est distribué le
lendemain
je sais que c'est compliqué mais c'est
la solution que nous avons proposé entre
rien et ça nous avons proposé ça et je
dois dire mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs que si j'ai
avaient à le faire je le referai et
après je vais vous dire s'il vous plaît
je vais vous dire en Suisse qui va se
passer soit nous trouverons 5 à 10 000
personnes par jour qu'il utiliseront ce
service et on continuera de le maintenir
soit personne n'en voudra et alors je
dirais on a proposé aux gens de se
servir de ça il n'en n'ont plus besoin
et on supprimera cela mais vraiment
j'assume aussi le fait de ne pas avoir
dit aux gens il y a plus aucune solution
il y en a une elle est moins
satisfaisante mais les besoins
devenaient tellement marginaux que
j'espère que ça va fonctionner
aujourd'hui cette îlette rouge est
utilisée 3500 fois par jour c'est pas
beaucoup fait toute façon dans quatre
ans comme il y avait plus de lettres
rouge ce sera plus que ce qui restait
donc voilà sur la lettre rouge je
tant que ce soit très symbolique et vous
voyez et depuis maintenant plus de 9 ans
nous avons l'habitude d'échanger quand
je vous dis nous perdons 12 milliards de
lettres c'est à chiffre fort et je sais
bien que ça ça vous impacte mais c'est
théorique quand je vous dis la Poste a
perdu 6 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires c'est-à-dire l'équivalent du
chiffre d'affaires de la RATP la
totalité perdue ou la totalité du
chiffre d'affaires de Dassault Systèmes
une des plus belles entreprises
numériques du pays ces théorique
résultat de ces pertes là pour la
première fois devient concret c'est que
la lettre rouge s'en va mais c'est la
traduction dans notre vie quotidienne de
ceux qui se passe c'est à dire que les
volumes ont été divisés par 3 et c'est
ça qui s'est passé et je pense que c'est
ça qu'il fallait faire si on veut
maintenir un service public et de ce
point de vue je veux à nouveau vous
remercier pour votre soutien puisque
madame la Présidente comme vous l'avez
signalé maintenant et tout a été
budgétisé on ne passe plus ni par le
compte du livret A ni par une dépense
fiscale sur la CVAE la totalité des
aides de la Poste passe par le budget il
se monte à 1,1 milliard donc je vous
remercie et dont je me permets tout de
même de souligner et là les rapports
sénatoriaux et le rapport
de Jean Launay l'ont montré le coût
global est quand même de 1 milliard 5 le
coup global est d'un milliard 5 nous
sommes compensés de 1,1 milliard je veux
insister mais ça vous montre aussi que
parfois une critique c'est vous voulez
faire de la rentabilité sur le service
public on en est très loin à 500
millions d'écarts on est très loin de la
rentabilité et je vais vous avouer que
ce n'est pas un de mes objectifs si on
pouvait compenser équilibrer les choses
ça me suffirait
je reviens donc sur les points pour
répondre à aux questions saillantes nous
allons continuer à passer par tout sur
le territoire
sur cette nous ne demandons aucun
aménagement comme la plupart des autres
postes et nous cherchons le plus
possible de services et de produits pour
nous arrêter le plus souvent possible et
donc garder l'emploi sur les territoires
et comme j'étais vendredi je l'ai dit
avant le début de notre réunion en
Ardennes à
Charleville j'ai vu à quel point dans le
rural le passage du facteur est clé et
c'est à ça que nous devons nous employer
donc voilà ce que je peux dire sur ce
sujet ce qui nous conduit aux missions
de service public nous venons de de
sortir à l'instant et ce n'est peut-être
pas hasard un communiqué de presse avec
la MF et l'État sur la signature par
nous trois d'un nouveau contrat
tripartit triennal entre l'État l'AMF et
la poste
il emporte à la demande des élus des
modifications majeures ça a été une
excellente négociation chacun des
partenaires a cherché à avancer sur ses
propres thèmes et nous sommes je pense
avec le ministre Bruno Le Maire et avec
David Lisnard et André leniel du côté de
la MF satisfait du résultat auquel nous
sommes arrivés qu'est-ce qu'on peut
annoncer de majeur comme avancé du
service public car je vois bien que dans
vos critiques il y a aussi le fait que
vous avez le sentiment qu'on assiste à
un abandon progressif et que c'est ça
qui vous inquiète et je le comprends ce
que nous annonçons dans ce contrat c'est
que nous allons ouvrir dans les 18 mois
1000 bureaux de poste le samedi ou le
jour du marché en semaine c'est une
demande récurrente de l'AMF on est en
train d'y répondre on a 7500 bureaux de
poste il y en a à peu près 1500 qui ne
sont pas ouvert le samedi on va
massivement les ouvrir pour montrer aux
gens que la Poste cherche à ouvrir
lorsqu'il y a de l'affluence et c'est un
point majeur du contrat obtenu par les
élus et accepté par nous-mêmes parce
qu'il va dans le sens du service public
nous nous engageons également sous le
contrôle de l'AMF à limiter de manière
considérable à quelque chose qui vous
gêne beaucoup et qui gêne nos clients
c'est les fermetures intempestives de
bureau de poste pourquoi y a-t-il pour
expliquer pourquoi il y en a plus
aujourd'hui qu'hier mais parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a plus de bureau de
Poste où il y a une seule personne qui a
20 ans il y a 20 ans il y avait très peu
de bureaux agent seul c'est le non
postal du bureau
solitaire si j'ose dire comme il y en a
plus quand la personne est malade ayant
eu beaucoup avec la covid on ferme là
aussi on a mis en place un plan
spécifique et sa répond d'ailleurs aux
demandes de votre rapport sénatorial on
a également pour les élus complètement
stabilisés les estivale nous même
qu'est-ce qu'on en a eu de plus et bien
nous intégrons dans ce contrat pour la
première fois la notion de fréquentation
et nous considérons que la fréquentation
devient un sujet commun entre le maire
et la poste
et que c'est à la fréquentation qu'il
faut que l'un et l'autre répondent
puisque s'il n'y a pas de fréquentation
on a du mal à ouvrir les bureaux de
poste donc ce contrat de présence
postale territoriale à travers
l'ouverture à venir le samedi et le jour
du marché en semaine fait un pas majeur
d'ouverture du service public c'est la
façon de vous montrer que nous sommes
extrêmement attentifs à ces missions de
service public et puis pour ne pas
abuser de de votre patience je voudrais
rassembler tout ça dans ce que depuis 10
ans sous votre regard nous sommes en
train de faire nous sommes en train de
faire prendre à 260 000 personnes et à
l'entreprise la plus ancienne de ce pays
un tournant stratégique
il y a 15 ans La Poste tournait autour
de la lettre la lettre abandonne la
poste dans l'histoire c'est pas la Poste
qui ne veut pas écrire moi-même je suis
un écrivain quasi frénétique j'envoie
énormément de cartes de vœux ça ne
suffit pas à redresser les chiffres mais
je le sais c'est pour ça que je vous en
parle
c'est pour ça que je vous en parle
c'est pour ça que je vous en parle et
bien nos efforts madame la Présidente
Mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs nos efforts ne suffisent pas
et ce qui doit nous rassurer c'est que
dans toute l'Europe et dans le monde
entier les lettres plongent nous sommes
en train de prendre ce tournant et nous
pouvons en juger ensemble lorsque la
Poste est créée par la loi qui laisse
Rocard en 90
70% du chiffre d'affaires c'est de la
lettre
j'arrive dans le groupe fin 2010
Jean-Paul Bailly avait évidemment
largement commencé le travail c'est 41%
du chiffre d'affaires à la fin de
l'année 2022 ce ne sera plus que 17% du
chiffre d'affaires ça veut dire que ce
tournant nous sommes en train de le
prendre nous sommes en train de le
prendre avec
les posters et les postiers parce qu'à
la fin du jour si la Poste est appréciée
et aimée c'est grâce à elle et grâce à
eux les factrices et les facteurs connus
sur tout le territoire raison pour
laquelle je le redis monsieur le
sénateur nous n'avons pas l'intention de
remettre en cause les quartiers lettres
c'est la base de notre organisation
c'est la base de l'organisation et
puisque vous l'avez mentionné madame la
Présidente nous n'avez aucune intention
de remettre en cause la distribution du
journal il y a par contre et c'est comme
ça qu'on discute ensemble depuis près de
10 ans une chose que je ne peux pas vous
promettre c'est de passer le matin si
vous donnez à matin la définition
espace-temps qui se termine à 12 heures
si c'est ça votre définition je peux pas
vous le perdre promettre pourquoi parce
que dans les bouts de tournée dans les
bouts des tournées on est au-delà de 12
heures et alors pourquoi est-on au bout
de 12 heures aujourd'hui et ne l'étions
pas il y a 15 ans pour une raison simple
c'est que les tournées sont allongées
elles se sont allongées parce qu'il y a
moins de facteurs et beaucoup moins de
l'être d'accord les lettres ont diminué
de deux tiers le nombre de facteurs n'a
diminué que de 1/3
et surtout toute la tournée aujourd'hui
ne tourne plus du tout autour de la
lettre la tournée à la poste tourne
autour du colis parce que nous sommes
devenus une entreprise de colis 17% de
lettres en chiffre d'affaires le colis
c'est 51%. la Poste est devenue une
entreprise de colis et par définition le
colis ça arrive plus tard si le colis
arrive plus tard les facteurs embauchent
plus tard s'ils embauchent plus tard ils
partent plus tard s'ils partent plus
tard il rentre plus tard et c'est la
raison pour laquelle
nous nous engageons et j'ai entendu un
sénateur pour lequel le service ne
fonctionnait pas en rural à distribuer
évidemment le journal tous les jours et
à nous arrêter tous les jours mais je ne
peux pas m'engager madame la Présidente
à passer avant midi ça ça n'est pas
possible ça n'est pas possible et
comment se fait la distribution du
journal en France
et on a un responsable au moins de
quotidien dans la salle
peu plus d'un tiers un peu plus d'un
tiers et distribué en kiosque
un tiers et distribué par les porteurs
un tiers et distribué par les post-its
le tiers des postiers c'est que du rural
dans les villes dans les grandes villes
il y a plus du tout de distribution par
la poste mais en rural comme les
tournées commencent plus tard et bien ne
passe pas nécessairement partout avant
12 heures en fait en fait le vrai
horaire madame la Présidente c'est pas
12 heures pour les Français c'est 13h et
le journal l'ex journal de Jean-Pierre
Pernaut et je me souviens une discussion
avec Jean-Michel bailette je peux les
partager avec vous qui n'était pas
content parce que trop de journaux
arrivaient après que Jean-Pierre Pernaut
ait commencé son journal son journal
télévisé
bien sûr mais je veux quand même dire
que la plupart des journaux arrivent
avant 12 heures mais quand on part une
heure et demie plutôt on se décale ça je
peux pas vous le promettre et d'ailleurs
ce serait ce serait pas correct de vous
le promets d'ailleurs des abonnements
enfin des de la presse la presse c'est
un volume important c'est à peu près un
tiers de nouveau volume c'est une part
majeure du déficit résiduel sur lequel
je n'avais pas à madame la Présidente
l'intention de revenir les 500 millions
mais vous m'y forcez on perd à chaque
exemplaire nous c'est pas pour vous
faire pleurer que je le dis on perd 40
centimes
on perd 40 centimes chaque fois qu'on
remet un quotidien même après la réforme
Genesis et là encore le rapport
sénatorial l'a montré donc vous voyez
que c'est une économie quand même très
contrainte je reviens sur le tournant le
tournant que nous sommes en train de
prendre il doit permettre d'assurer la
pérennité de l'entreprise et cette année
on devrait gagner plus d'un milliard
comme l'année dernière je peux pas vous
donner les chiffres exacts parce qu'ils
sortent la semaine prochaine et on n'a
pas eu notre conseil d'administration je
pense que pour la commission des
affaires économiques du Sénat c'est une
bonne nouvelle qu'une grande entreprise
publique comme cela gagne de l'argent
j'avance voilà premièrement non non on
en gagne voilà on fait on fait ce
mouvement et la diversification vous
l'avez dit c'est la seule réponse à la
trission du métier historique le groupe
est devenu un groupe diversifié colis
courrier journaux services où est-ce
qu'on en est nos fameux services lancés
parfois sous les moqueries en 2013 et
bien ils vont faire 700 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires c'est pas encore
gagné et il y a un service dont nous
sommes extrêmement fiers et sur lequel
il faut que avec les associations et les
élus nous allions beaucoup plus loin
c'est le service de livraison de repas
ce que je sais ça je le sais de mes
voyages du vendredi et dans la période
récente c'était Charleville-Mézières
lent et le blessoir ce sera bien trop la
Corrèze c'est que c'est un service qui
se développe partout soit sur base du
CCAS soit sur base associatif
et ça nous devons en devenir le leader
et vous voyez bien je reviens à la
question du Six Jours sur 7 même la
présidente si nous sommes le leader de
la livraison de millions et de millions
de repas quotidiens et bien les tournées
sont sauvées pour le dire autrement et
donc c'est ça vers quoi nous allons il y
a 5 ans La Poste livraison repas
quotidien à la fin de l'année dernière 3
l'objectif de cette année c'est 5
millions
et par exemple dans le besoin où on l'a
visité il y a aujourd'hui 7 tournées
totalement dédiée à la distribution des
repas dans la ville de Nice qui a des
caractéristiques particulières en termes
d'âge moyen de ses habitants 17
c'est factuel madame la sénatrice
la première des niçoise ici attention
je reviens je reviens au fait
tourner 17 tournées sont totalement
dédiés au repas donc si vous me demandez
quel est l'avenir des facteurs et tous
les vendredis c'est la question les
facteurs qu'est-ce qu'on va devenir
c'est plus de services
plus de colis et un peu de logistique
supplémentaire parce qu'on est en train
de prendre de la logistique industrielle
et vous le voyez bien que ça fait
évidemment
fusion avec mon argument essentiel le
sujet c'est pas de passer moins c'est de
s'arrêter le plus souvent possible et ça
il faut le trouver avec les élus sur
place et avec les associations ce qui
est remarquable dans le service de
convivialité sociale que nous faisons
dans le cadre de l'appât en Mayenne
c'est que le département a ses agents il
utilise la ldmr et l'utilise la poste ce
que je veux dire c'est que les besoins
tirés du vieillissement de la population
sont-elles qu'il y aura de la place pour
tout le monde
et je pense qu'il est mieux que ses
services soient assurés par des
factrices et des facteurs dans leur
quartier lettres que par une filiale
d'un fond de privety de quelques
nationalités qu'ils soient voilà ce que
je me permets de dire même si la Banque
Postale finance tout le monde dans le
pays je veux l'avoir dit donc vous voyez
que nous restons ferme sur notre
orientation stratégique six jours sur
cette quotidienne nous voulons défendre
nos missions de service public et nous
sommes en train de prendre ce virage et
je voudrais dire que dans ce virage il y
a deux métiers pour 2030 et 2035 les
services de proximité humaine dont on
vient parler que ce soit une visite de
convivialité pure si j'ose dire comme
dans la Mayenne de livraison de
médicaments de livraisons de repas
ou de prévention au travers du Bien
vieillir en ce moment même en ce moment
même il y a un travail partout au
Parlement au CNR sur le Bien Vieillir il
y a là une infrastructure humaine à
travers les posters et les postiers qui
est exceptionnel parce qu'elle connaît
la totalité du territoire ça c'est une
partie de l'avenir de la poste le
tournant on est en train de le prendre
et il faut le réussir et puis le
deuxième vous y avez fait référence
c'est le numérique car fort de la
confiance tangible qu'ils ont accumulé
et qu'ils font vivre avec les Français
les postiers peuvent bénéficier d'une
confiance numérique on a confiance dans
digiposte notre coffre-fort électronique
parce qu'on a confiance dans la Poste sa
factrice et son facteur
nous sommes devenus le premier
coffre-fort électronique en France 9
millions de digipost et j'espère que
nous allons passer les 10 millions cette
année premier point deuxième point
l'identité numéro 1 je vois que vous
l'avez présente c'est bien alors je vais
m'en là maintenant que la présidente m'a
mis au défi il faut quand même que je
vous montre le mien sinon ça fait passer
sérieux voilà alors moi j'ai aussi
digiposte je vous le recommande je vous
le recommande pour tous les éléments de
votre vie numérique l'identité numérique
nous sommes le seul détenteur d'une
identité substantielle et vous avez été
vous-même dans les travaux du Sénat très
attentifs aux difficultés du compte
personnel de formation et des
escroqueries avec le gouvernement et la
Caisse des dépôts est consignations nous
avons mis entre le compte personnel
formation et le client l'identité
numérique de la poste et les
escroqueries ont fondu pour ceux qui ont
une identité numérique donc le numérique
ne croyez pas que ce soit marginal dans
notre avenir
central et Docapost notre filiale
numérique là encore sera à pas loin d'un
milliard d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
et nous allons continuer à investir
parce que si on a confiance dans la
poste on a confiance dans le numérique
de la poste et je pense qu'on aura un
chiffre d'affaires considérable dans les
années à venir et donc au moment où on
se retournera sur notre histoire on dira
je l'espère que nous avons été capable
sous votre contrôle et en vous rendant
compte de faire prendre à cette
entreprise le tournant économique
qu'elle doit prendre c'est ça qu'on est
en train de faire et dans ce tournant le
mouvement est toujours guidé par le
passage quotidien six jours sur 7 mais
le timbre rouge était un moment de
l'histoire et comme les gens ne
l'utilisent plus et bien on l'a laissé
et il accompagne ce tournant le but
c'est bien ça une entreprise qui reste
une entreprise de service public qui se
développe
qui est capable de croître et qui est
capable de tenir les missions de service
public auquel vous êtes si attachés je
ne suis pas sûr d'avoir répondu à toutes
vos questions mais je pense qu'elles
vont maintenant arriver les unes après
les autres et dans cette affaire du
timbre rouge il y a tout sauf de la
surprise car si on allume le rapport
pardon de d'y rendre à nouveau hommage
mais le rapport de votre commission on
sait ce qu'il devait se passer c'était
écrit et c'est normal que c'était écrit
parce que tout ça c'est très industriel
et nous l'avons fait quand il fallait le
faire
voilà madame la Présidente à ce stade
mes réponses monsieur le Président comme
vous l'indiquez il y a beaucoup de
questions et donc je vais donner la
parole aux trois auteurs d'abord du
rapport je vais commencer par Patrick
chaise ensuite pierregot Rémy Cardon
merci madame la Présidente et merci
monsieur le Président pour ces propos
liminaires qui comme toujours sont
parfaitement détaillés et complets je me
permettrai néanmoins de revenir sur
quelques questions donc de précision
notamment sur le déficit des missions de
service public
pouvez-vous monsieur le Président nous
détailler mission par mission les
déficits constatés et on regarde les
compensations qui sont obtenus en effet
il apparaît que selon la source il y a
un mélange qui n'est pas à la
transparence et à la compréhension de de
ces
différentes missions ainsi la recette
indiquait lors d'une audition à la
commission supérieure du numérique à des
postes un déficit de 1 milliard 7 pour
le seul service universel postal
sur la mission de contribution à
l'aménagement du territoire donc en 2023
un nouveau contrat de présence postale
territoriale doit entrer en vigueur les
négociations donc sont terminées vous
n'avez annoncé vous avez donné donc
effectivement votre assiettement sur ce
contrat
pensez-vous que ce contrat donc et une
bonne formulation de renouvellement
puisqu'on a un cycle de trois ans pour
le rediscuter
sur le ce point aussi le Parlement a
besoin davantage de transparence il me
semble que des garanties essentielles
doivent être préservées vous l'avez donc
vous en avez évoqué certains mais je
voudrais et moi évoquer la consommation
du pouvoir de veto pour les mers
dans le cas de transformation des
bureaux de poste implantés sur le
territoire de leur commune
sur les compensations je voudrais savoir
si vous paraissent adapté sur la seule
mission aménagement du territoire
l'estimation de la recette est au double
de la compensation
qu'en pensez-vous c'est pas ça
en fait sur le contrat de présence
postale et de vous satisfait de
négociation passé même si vous l'avez
déjà évoqué pouvez-vous vous exposer
donc des points sur lesquels peut-être
des avancées n'aurait pas eu lieu et
serait souhaitable pour la poste et
pensez-vous que la sous-compensation a
des effets sur la qualité de ses
avancées attendues je reviendrai
rapidement sur le timbre rouge vous le
savez monsieur le Président la nouvelle
réforme de ces nombreuses postaux
suscite de nombreuses critiques et
interrogations à titre personnel je
pense que c'est très fort et justifiée
sous réserve que le courrier continue de
distribuer 6 jours sur 7 comme vous
l'avez précisé et que les lettres
recommandées et les titres de presse
puissent continuer à distribuer en J+1
sur l'ensemble du territoire et que le
J+3 soit réellement respecté je crois
que c'est sur ce point que aujourd'hui
il y a une attention particulière une
question un peu particulière qui est
demandé par ma collègue Martine Berthet
qui m'a chargé de vous la poser c'est la
livraison des colis on étage est-ce que
donc le facteur va pouvoir notamment
pour les personnes âgées amener donc
le colis directement au lieu
d'habitation plutôt que de laisser dans
la boîte aux lettres qui se situe en bas
je te contre un entreprises juste
d'accord
en 2023 doit également entrer vigueur le
nouveau contrat d'entreprise signée
entre la poste et l'État ce nouveau
contrat est-il prêt et qu'elles en sont
les principales orientations et les
principales nouveautés
je vous remercie Patrick pierre lot
oui monsieur le Président c'est vrai que
lors de notre travail en commission nous
avions préconisé le développement des
services de proximité de La Poste pour
réduire le déficit on doit bien
reconnaître que l'avancement vers ce
service de proximité
n'est pas aussi rapide qu'on le
souhaitait que vous le souhaitiez et je
voulais vous demander si vous aviez
entrepris un travail avec les gens qui
ont fait le métier ou danser le
financement des conseils départementaux
les associations locales de maintien à
domicile
je crois qu'il est obligatoirement une
complémentarité moi je vois par exemple
dans mon village et bien il y a une
voiture qui apporte les repas de la
salle et il y a le facteur qui passe
tous les jours bon c'est pas cohérent
c'est pas économique ça va pas dans le
sens d'une nouvelle économie je voulais
vous demander si vous alliez
entreprendre des efforts beaucoup plus
cibler pour développer ses services de
proximité et vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure le tournant économique par le
digital je crois que aujourd'hui un
déroule de la poste c'est
le la rencontre des personnes au
quotidien et c'est ce qu'attendent
beaucoup les personnes âgées du facteur
et il faut le rendre stabiliser il faut
le rentabiliser je suis d'accord mais il
y a souvent un chevauchement qui ne
rentabilise pas et je voulais vous
demander quel était véritablement votre
stratégie à la fois vers les personnes
âgées et vers la fever économique qui
sont différents mais qui sont deux
moyens de rentabilité votre travail
merci Pierre Rémy Cardon merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président
Directeur j'aimerais déjà mettre un peu
de prudence sur vos propos sur le fait
que le rapport de la commission
n'exprime pas en faveur le remplacement
de ta voix rouge par la lettre rouge
vous avez été vous avez rectifié au fur
et à mesure de l'argumente de votre
argumentation mais tout de même je
voulais rappeler et puis derrière tout
ça bah du coup la question que je me
pose c'est comment vous avez pu préciser
les auditions de ce rapport qui a eu
effectivement une la moitié des
effectifs en disant qui a été supprimé
au groupe La Poste est-ce que avec
l'arrêt de ce tableau rouge c'est aussi
des perspectives avec une
des perspective assez négative avec des
suppressions de poste derrière vraiment
une question que je me pose et ou alors
il y a des reconversions de la formation
pour orienter sur des nouveaux services
et donc là aussi j'aimerais faire un
focus sur ce qu'on avait échangé suite
aux expérimentations qui qui ont été
conçus par votre groupe sur le aller
vers avec la poche à domicile en matière
de pour détecter en tout cas la
précarité énergétique ou encore sur la
fracture numérique est-ce que il y a des
choses qui vont être amplifiées parce
que pour l'instant c'est des
expérimentations sur des territoires
donnés mais ce qu'il y a des
perspectives plus réjouissantes sur le
travail sur l'ensemble du territoire
français et puis question très courte
est-ce que vous avez pris connaissance
de la proposition de loi de Jean-Claude
Tissot sur l'accessibilité et
l'inclusion bancaire puisque là encore
il y a aussi une proposition là qui a
été déposée il y a quelques mois qui va
qui pourrait changer la donne pour vous
aussi sur ce sujet
merci beaucoup Rémi je vais proposer au
président de répondre à ces premières
questions avant de prendre des très
nombreuses autres questions très bien je
crois effectivement que dans la mesure
où les trois sénateurs ont travaillé je
les en remercie sur notre entreprise il
est important de prendre leur question
monsieur le sénateur Cardon je n'ai
jamais dit que vous aviez préconisé il
est trop rouge jamais et d'ailleurs j'ai
moi-même dit la première décision c'est
mettre fin à la lettre rouge et après
comment le faire la voix que nous avons
choisie est plus compliqué elle fait un
peu plus de bruit mais elle va peut-être
se révéler utile ça je ne le sais pas
c'est les usagers qui vont choisir sur
les suppressions de post bien sûr il y a
eu des suppressions de poste dans notre
entreprise comment pourrait-il en être
autrement lorsque les facteurs
distribués 18 milliards de lettres et
qu'il n'en distribue plus que 6 le
modèle social c'est la reconversion
interne c'est un modèle massif qui
fonctionne bien lorsque vous visitez
j'espère qu'on sera organisé une telle
visite la nouvelle plateforme colis de
Montereau sur le Jard qui vraiment en
haut de la technologie et bien la
plupart des gens qui sont là sont
d'anciens facteurs et une autre
entreprise n'aurait pas fait ça elle
aurait adressé cette main d'oeuvre à
Pôle emploi c'est pas comme ça que nous
faisons et je pense que ce pacte social
est d'ailleurs reconnu à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise tout le combat et c'était
la raison pour laquelle je parle bien
d'un combat nous souhaitons nous arrêter
plus souvent encore dans le futur c'est
de nourrir les tournées de facteurs
d'autres choses que la lettre puisque la
lettre est condamnée au déclin c'est
tout notre sujet alors
nous avons mené énormément
d'expérimentations et votre question sur
l'amplification et la question clé pour
les nouveaux services dans les années à
venir
contrairement à beaucoup de choses ces
nouveaux services ne sont pas
relatifs à une mission nationale il
dépend pour la plupart des collectivités
locales et par exemple bien sûr et c'est
également une une question posée par
Monsieur le Sénateur lourd ça dépend de
chacun des conseils départementaux et
donc on a trouvé un accord avec la
Mayenne mais il faut le multiplier par
102 c'est ça notre sujet vous voyez
alors comme on est partout on s'y est
force mais il y a des différences de
tonalité et de tonalité je vais pas dire
autre chose sur le territoire avec les
103 conseils départementaux organisation
parce qu'ils ont d'autres organisations
d'autres priorités on a par exemple dans
les Landes avec le Conseil départemental
l'animation conjointe entre le Conseil
et nous-mêmes d'un village Alzheimer
mais là aussi il faudrait le multiplier
par 102 vous voyez donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous avez
noté tous les trois que ça ne va pas
assez vite je suis d'accord avec vous
nos syndicats le disent ce qui est une
excellente nouvelle pour le patron que
je suis mais après il faut vendre et
convaincre voyez c'est un conseil
départemental mais il faut le convaincre
parce qu'il a ses priorités etc alors on
le fait en Mayenne on le fait dans
l'heure on le fait par mais on n'est pas
partout et la difficulté c'est qu'il n'y
a pas une seule politique nationale il
faut le jouer département par
département et pour la livraison de
repas c'est CCAS par CCAS donc on parle
plus de 103 compétition commerciale on
parle de 6000 à 7000 compétitions
commerciales mais nous allons le faire
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est que cette
année nous allons distribuer 5 millions
on en distribue à 0 mais il faut que
vous conceviez comme moi et je vois que
vous êtes au moins aussi impatient que
moi que ça prenne un peu de temps au
total pour tous les trois je veux vous
le dire nos nouveaux services faisaient
0 millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
en 2013 ils vont faire 700 millions en
2022 alors c'est un peu la caverne
d'Alibaba il y a de tout il y a le code
de la route que vous avez utilisé et
autorisé il y a les économies d'énergie
qui se développent très bien il y a les
repas et les médicaments mais rien ne
remplacera la puissance de la
distribution de la lettre et pour ça il
nous faut du temps et d'ailleurs vous le
voyez bien prendre un tournant c'est
comme dans la vie réelle ça prend du
temps sinon on sort de la route donc
c'est c'est ça le sujet
l'expérimentation exactement comme
chacun de vous trois moi j'aimerais bien
que ça aille plus vite et que on
massifie le débat en ce moment et qui
passera devant vous sur l'organisation
du Bien Vieillir va évidemment être une
occasion en or
c'est à dire que il y a peu
d'organisations sur le territoire qui
est cette capacité de contact et de
rentrer à domicile chez tous les
Françaises et tous les Français ça ce
sont les factrices et les facteurs et
donc il y a un enjeu absolument clé au
cours de cette année sur la livraison
des colis à l'étage pour
patri chaise en fait Patrick chest ça
dépend pourquoi non mais attendez si
l'ascenseur est en panne ou pas mais
voilà il y a des dans certains quartiers
du pays les habitants nous demandent de
laisser les colis au bureau de poste
parce qu'ils ont peur que les boîtes aux
lettres soient visitées avant leur
propre passage dans d'autres le facteur
monte dans d'autres il veut pas monter
parce qu'il veut retrouver sa cargaison
à son retour surtout pendant les fêtes
de fin d'année et tout ça vous le savez
vous êtes des élus de terrain vous le
savez mais on est confronté à ça on est
confronté à ça je veux redire et ce
n'est pas anecdotique que notamment dans
l'espace rural les factrices et les
facteurs sauf plusieurs centaines de
personnes par an avec les services de
secours les toubibs et les et les
pompiers voyez donc je peux pas répondre
autre chose qui soit honnête et qui soit
ça dépend mais l'idée c'est bien d'aller
à la porte des gens et l'accent que nous
mettons sur la livraison des repas c'est
ça le repas on va pas le laisser dans la
boîte aux lettres ça ça va pas le faire
donc on va aller chez les gens et c'est
quelque chose qui est fondamental alors
vous m'aviez
posé la question des missions de service
public monsieur le sénateur je vais vous
donner les chiffres que j'ai moi qui je
ne suis pas sûr que ce soit les chiffres
définitifs voilà alors l'accessibilité
bancaire on aura une compensation de 321
millions et nous estimons nous que nous
avons un déficit net de compensation de
l'aménagement du territoire
nous avons nous allons recevoir 174 + 3
ce qui devrait faire 177 nous estimons
que nous avons un déficit net de 150
millions la distribution de la presse
nous allons recevoir 84 millions nous
estimons que nous avons un déficit net
de compensation de 197 c'est conformes à
ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est ce qui coûte le plus cher et le
service universel postal nous avons
recevoir 520 millions d'euros et nous
avons un déficit de compensation stricte
d'une vingtaine de millions d'euros
voilà les chiffres que nous avons nous
voilà
c'est ce qu'on peut dire
sur le J+2 je rappelle que au timbre
rouge a succédé le timbre turquoise qui
vous permet en plus d'avoir un suivi
c'est le J+2 et la lettre verte qui
était J + 2 est devenue J+3 donc la
Poste contribue à distribuer des lettres
et
car ce veto du maire c'est quelque chose
que nous avons négocié avec François
Baroin à l'époque
la Poste n'y était pas favorable la
poche j'entends les dirigeants
opérationnels sur le territoire étaient
pour une version la plus étroite
possible du véto
ce n'était pas ma vision pourquoi parce
que je considère qu'il ne peut pas y
avoir de réorganisation si on n'est pas
d'accord avec le maire et donc lever tôt
systémiquement force à trouver un accord
avec les élus et je m'en félicite je
reviens enfin parce que madame la
Présidente vous l'avez glissé sur les 68
expérimentations courrier de tout à
l'heure
comme il ne s'agit pas de changer le
passage quotidien mais c'est la bonne
foi on a pensé que c'était un truc
complètement technique et on s'est dit
on va pas déranger les mers pour quelque
chose technique on les a vu tous les 68
depuis hein à cause du bruit médiatique
mais vous savez tous les deux ans ont
réorganise les tournées les facteurs et
c'est un des éléments de l'usure pour
nos facteurs tous les deux ans on revoit
leur tournée pourquoi mais parce qu'en
deux ans les volumes ont baissé de 20%
et qu'il faut réajuster mais quand on
change les tournées on va pas prévenir
le maire c'est de l'opérationnel vous
voyez mais justement pour qu'il n'y ait
pas d'ambiguïté et comme le six jours
sur 7 et le passage quotidien n'est
jamais expérimenté on est allé voir les
mers pour les rassurer sur ce point
voilà l'idée qu'on peut dire donc il y a
pas d'expérimentation au sens du passage
quotidien il y a de l'expérimentation je
vais vous donner un exemple si vous êtes
en rural la fusion des flux c'est
beaucoup de journaux en rural un peu de
colis un peu de lettres et des services
quand vous êtes en urbain il y a des
tournées qui ne font que des lettres et
donc l'organisation n'est pas la même
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans
l'expérimentation il y a Ploërmel il y a
pas mis il y a Lyon à 3e arrondissement
vous voyez bien que ça n'a rien à voir
c'est ça qu'on expérimente c'est pas
autre chose très bien monsieur le
Président je vais commencer le grand
tunnel des questions je demandais à mes
collègues d'aller à l'essentiel bien sûr
ce que vous êtes très très nombreux et
d'éviter si possible et si vous le
souhaitez les redondances voilà Fabien
gay ensuite Ghislaine Pantel
sur le Président Directeur Général
bonjour j'espère que vous allez bien
monsieur
et c'est
ça l'essentiel deux questions la
première sur le thème rouge revient pas
sur la polémique moi elle m'intéresse
pas sur les mails payants etc mais le
thème rouge c'était la promesse
républicaine que le on écrivait le
lendemain on l'avait et vous le savez
vous l'avez dit c'est un totem mais vous
êtes chef d'entreprise vous devez
prendre des décisions
entreprise publique donc équilibrer les
comptes mais aussi faire du service
public mais moi je trouve qu'il y a une
contradiction pour le coup de la poche
me permet de le poser ici parce que on
est dans une compétition où par exemple
la livraison du colis le matin je peux
commander sur mon iphone le soir je suis
livré et vous vous prenez une décision
c'est dire
pour le coup la lettre vous allez
l'envoyer aujourd'hui vous allez
recevoir dans trois jours et pareil pour
le colis non mais je dis ça je trouve
qu'il y a une contradiction si on veut
être compétitif puisque vous parlez
rentabilité compétitivité on est dans
une compétitivité et aujourd'hui moi ce
que j'entends d'une entreprise publique
ce qui a rempli sa mission de
républicaine mais qu'elles sont aussi
compétitives et voilà et je dis ça et
qu'en plus on voit livraison de colis
sur Chronopost je prends mon département
et vous le savez je voulais déjà dit
c'est lamentable je le dis on peut pas
me répondre il y a des problèmes on va
pas livrer alors qu'Amazon livre toute
la journée et la moitié des colis sont
arrivés en état pitoyable et moi-même
régulièrement j'ai des colis
défoncés ou regarder et en plus à chaque
fois on n'a pas le papier dans la boîte
aux lettres il faut aller à la poste
centrale moi je peux me le permettre
mais je pense à celles et ceux qui sont
en difficulté pour se déplacer donc là
il y a je me permets de vous le dire je
trouve une contradiction et la deuxième
chose je vais pas le plus loin on aura
le débat mais si j'étais éditeur de
presse
il y aura un peu de débat voilà non mais
je vous dis ça je vous dis ça parce que
vous dites ça nous coûte ça coûte aux
éditeurs presse
ils vont être de moins en moins et vous
le savez indemnisé pour cette question
là non mais voilà et il y a une question
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les zones peu
denses c'est même pas après midi
ou 13h qui sont livrés c'est en général
et vous le savez on a déjà eu ce débat
pour 30%
en tout cas de celles et ceux qui sont
abonnés aux journaux ils ne reçois pas
le journal dans la journée et donc là
aussi il y a un problème c'est que vous
êtes prestataire entre guillemets des
éditeurs de presse dans un partenariat
républicain et on peut pas augmenter
chaque année le prix que les subventions
baissent pour les éditeurs et que le
journal soit pas livré là il y a une
petite contradiction mais nous aurons
l'occasion dans d'autres circonstances
tout à l'heure sur ce sujet
monsieur le Président
vous nous avez dit que la suppression du
timbre rouge sauvé le service public
mais va supprimer combien d'emplois de
facteurs que ce soit des emplois de
distribution ou des emplois dans les
plateformes de courrier
ensuite vous nous avez dit aussi que les
il faut envoyer enfin à la place il y
avait une lettre une lettre rouge
mais encore au foot mais il faut se
rendre dans le bureau de Poste encore
faut-il que les bureaux de poste soient
ouverts parce que nous avons nous avons
dans nos pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas
avec la fracture numérique pour ceux qui
ne peuvent pas le faire par internet il
faut se rendre dans les bureaux de poste
mais les bureaux de poste dans tous les
départements ruraux je vous parle de la
Lozère mais tous les départements ruraux
hyper ruraux de France je pense on a la
même situation il y a beaucoup de
fermetures
inopinées voilà dans les dans les
bureaux de poste donc c'est un vrai vrai
problème parce qu'il faut vous savez
très bien comment sont les la géographie
du département ruraux il faut prendre sa
voiture et se déplacer faire des fois
des demi-heure de route donc c'est très
très compliqué
et
pour ce qui la modernisation des
services nécessite parfois un
accompagnement donc des usagers pour
réduire la fracture numérique ces
dernières années la Poste a investi pour
déployer de nouvelles structures comme
France service au sein de son réseau
serait-il possible pour que vous nous
communiquiez le nombre de bureaux de
poste labellisés France service et
combien sont encore en projet
voilà merci merci président merci merci
Ghislaine ensuite Michelin et ensuite
Évelyne renaud-garabédian merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Président la
loi de finances pour 2023 a permis une
évolution importante pour le soutien
pouvoir d'achat des ménages ultramarins
et la continuité territoriale des
services postaux en effet la franchise
de taxation à l'octroi de mer et à la
TVA pour les colis qui font l'objet on
voit nos commerciaux par la poste et
passer 205 à 400 euros c'est une bonne
mesure qui devrait faciliter les envois
d'effet personnels et familiaux et les
échanges quotidiens entre l'hexagone et
les territoires ultramarins monsieur le
Président cette mesure est-elle
désormais opérationnelle est-elle
appliquée par vos services chargés du
dédouanement des colis et je me permets
par ailleurs de préciser que si cette
mesure va dans le bon sens l'enjeu est
désormais celui d'une évolution des
frais pour les envois commerciaux le
développement du e-commerce dans
territoire demeurant fortement pénalisé
merci beaucoup Micheline Evelyne Renaud
garabéeian et ensuite Dominique Estrosi
merci ma présidente monsieur le
Président j'ai deux questions à vous
poser qui concernent les Français que je
représente dans le monde ils accèdent à
l'ensemble de leurs démarches
administratives via la plateforme France
Connect l'identité numérique de la Poste
est pour eux l'un de ses moyens de
connexion mais malheureusement elle
n'est possible aujourd'hui que dans une
quarantaine de pays elle n'est pas
toujours fonctionnelle dans les pays où
elle fonctionne notamment au Canada et
elle devait être étendue à 49 pays en
2022 et à peu près dans tout le
territoire mondial à partir de 2023
qu'en est-il du calendrier du
déploiement de l'identité numérique et
son fonctionnement réel hors de France
ma deuxième question pour simplifier les
démarches et digitaliser les services la
Poste propose la possibilité d'ouvrir un
compte bancaire grâce à cette identité
numérique les Français qui vivent à
l'étranger se voient régulièrement fermé
leur compte bancaire par les banques en
grande majorité en raison de la
réglementation qui vise à lutter contre
le blanchiment d'argent et le
financement du terrorisme pouvez-vous
nous indiquer si nos compatriotes
français vivant à l'étranger peuvent
utiliser ce nouveau service bancaire et
si oui est-ce que vous pouvez mettre en
contact avec l'un de vos collaborateurs
pour que nous puissions en discuter avec
lui merci
merci beaucoup Evelyne Dominique Estrosi
ça sonne ensuite Daniel Laurent merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général deux
questions l'une sur l'actualité colis de
la poste le groupe a signé le 7 février
2023 un partenariat avec la CMA CGM et
plus particulièrement un accord avec
geoposte l'outil de livraison de la
poste et la CEVA logistique pour le
transport des colis pouvez nous
pouvez-vous nous en dire un peu plus sur
vos attentes et les enjeux de ce
partenariat qui sommes toutes bien sûr
et très récents s'agit-il plutôt d'une
nouvelle stratégie de livraison au
dernier kilomètre dans les départements
français ou bien d'un renforcement de la
Poste à l'international et puis une
question sur le bouclier bancaire le
ministère de l'Économie des Finances
avait promis un bouclier bancaire pour
2023 et les banques s'étaient engagées
en fin d'année dernière à limiter la
hausse des frais la Banque Postale est
en tête du classement puisque c'est
établissement bancaire le moins cher
dans la région métropolitaine toutefois
en novembre dernier une enquête moneyvox
avait indiqué l'absence de régulation
pour les frais bancaires notamment les
frais de succession ou certaines
opérations coûtent plus cher d'être mort
que vivant ou des transferts sont
gratuits il y a d'autres inconvénients à
adopter une proposition de loi tout
récemment pour renforcer la protection
des épargnants et au cours de l'examen
de ce texte de loi au Sénat il y a un
amendement qui a été voté à l'unanimité
qui encadrent les frais bancaires de
succession en supprimant les frais en
cas de clôture d'un compte inférieur à
5000 euros le gouvernement s'est opposé
à cet amendement expliquant qu'une
négociation était en cours avec les
banques permettant de négocier les
tarifs et de les harmoniser sans
légiférer alors est-ce que le
gouvernement a dit vrai sur
l'aboutissement de cette négociation et
d'autres sujets sur d'autres frais
bancaires sont-ils aujourd'hui en cours
de négociation merci Dominique Daniel
Laurent suite Bernard buis oui monsieur
le Président de deux questions vous avez
répondu d'ailleurs à beaucoup d'autres
dans nos territoires la poste et les
élus travaillent vous l'avez exprimé de
concert au sein des commissions
départementales de présence postale dans
mon département d'ailleurs ça fonctionne
bien il n'en demeure pas moins que les
élus sont toujours très attentifs et
très préoccupés sur les points suivants
l'horaire des bureaux de poste ça c'est
un point essentiel l'accessibilité
bancaire et vous n'en n'avez pas parlé
la dépose de distributeur automatique et
dans le milieu rural c'est important la
deuxième question ça concerne la
Commission européenne la commission
supérieure du numérique et des postes a
rendu un avis le 14 décembre 2022 sur le
bilan du dispositif des conseillers
numériques lancées il y a deux ans avec
pour objectif de proposer un
accompagnement individuel et des
ateliers d'initiation numérique
dans ces recommandations le Commission
propose d'associer plus étroitement la
poste au dispositif afin que son rôle
soit mieux reconnu notamment en matière
de détection et d'accompagnement elle
recommande également que les
collectivités soient mieux associées à
l'exercice de concertation qui sera
piloté par la maintenance
médiation numérique que les fonds
européens soient davantage mobilisés ou
encore que soit identifié le bon niveau
de pilotage du dispositif entre les
bassins de vie et la région sachant que
les départements étant sont souvent les
mieux placés pour détecter les besoins
qu'en est-il monsieur le Président merci
Daniel la parole est à Bernard but
ensuite Anne-Catherine Loisier merci
présidente merci monsieur le Président
pour vos propos clair net et précis la
Poste poursuit son investissement dans
la décourbonation de sa flotte plus de
la moitié de vos véhicules seront
prochainement électrique avez-vous fixé
une date pour avoir une flotte
intégralement électrique ou décarbonée
voilà une question directe merci Bernard
24 innoisier ensuite anne-champ Larcher
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président deux questions complémentaires
à celle posée par mes collègues puisque
un certain nombre de dispositifs au
moment où c'était vu pour les examens
budgétaires a été suspendu à des
décisions de la Commission européenne
donc s'agissant du déficit du service
postal
qu'en est-il à ce jour est-ce que la
communion a validé les dispositifs de
même pour la réforme du transport et de
la distribution de la presse quels sont
les perspectives et notamment pour les
zones rurales montagneuses ou peu dense
merci merci
Françoise Ferrat ensuite Daniel
Grémillet merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président vous n'avez pas
évoqué les points de contact postaux en
octobre 2018 dans cette même salle nous
évoquions avec vous cette ce point
précisément et vous avez là aussi
précisément évoquer le chiffre de 17000
232 points
en contact vous tôt parmi lesquels 8000
bureaux de poste traditionnels cette
mise agence postale communale et le
reste constitué d'environ 1500 commerces
en zone rurale monsieur le Président
17232 en 2018 combien aujourd'hui
deuxième question vous évoquez 1000
ouverture supplémentaires le samedi
pouvez-vous nous apporter quelques
précisions sur cette nouvelle
organisation parce que nous y sommes
particulièrement attachés en zone rurale
vous l'avez bien compris
et ailleurs aussi Daniel grimillet
ensuite
Patricia chez nager oui merci présidente
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
trois questions la première
effectivement le l'enjeu du portage des
repas à domicile une question
complémentaire c'est est-ce que la poste
peut s'intéresser ou pas au circuit
court donc relation directe territoriale
deuxième question
pas question mais d'appuyer le
l'importance vous l'avez évoqué des
discussions avec les mères parce que on
est très souvent sollicité et on se rend
compte après coup qu'effectivement la
fermeture parfois donne des solutions
meilleures après lorsqu'on a une bonne
organisation avec une amplitude
importante j'insiste sur la préparation
de de ce passage d'un fermeture à un
autre service
autre question Bernard a posé la
question de la décarbonation
je sais que les flottes et vous en
faites partie peuvent être source de
progrès on a un défi dans notre pays on
parle de la mobilité électrique moi je
voudrais vous parler de la mobilité
véhicule hydrogène est-ce que la poste
peut ou pas l'imaginer parce que ça sera
un vecteur absolument essentiel
d'industrialisation de cette nouvelle
mobilité et puis dernière petite
remarque présidente l'expérience puisque
à des collègues qui vont être
renouvelables en 20223 pour l'avoir vécu
en 2020 quand même parfois c'est
choquant de voir qu'on constate qu'avec
des timbres plus d'une centaine de
lettres ne sont jamais arrivés à leur
destinataire alors est-ce que c'était le
covid mais je le dis parce que je n'ai
pas été le seul et sans aucune
explication
merci merci Daniel Patricia scheninger
et pour terminer Michel bonus c'est
d'autres demandes merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président
Directeur c'est pas la première fois que
je pose cette question elle est depuis
quelques années certainement redondantes
et j'ai des collègues qui sont aussi
élus en zone frontale hier vous savez
que je suis dans le Haut-Rhin donc
proche de la Suisse nous rencontrons
effectivement de gros problèmes de
recrutement vous savez que la Suisse
avait minimum 3500 francs suisses de
salaire et maintenant un SMIC à 4500
euros vers Genève fait en nous une zone
vraiment de désert je dirais de
personnel et ceux qui entraîne aussi
tous vos projets que vous avez de lien
direct avec soit des personnes âgées
soit bah la livraison de de postes
est-ce que vous avez vous anticipez
parce que bon c'est assez récent
l'augmentation de du salaire minimum
mais vous dire que vraiment on est très
très inquiet dans alors qu'on est un
bassin de vie de plus de 80 000
habitants et aussi des entreprises très
présentes autour de l'aéroport
Bâle-Mulhouse merci patrici
a merci Président je voudrais relever le
tour que je fais avec les mers du
département du Var c'est déjà si il faut
prendre parti à la cartographie vous
mettez en place sur notre département
parce que pour vous aider et pour
partager avec vous et après un
partenariat qui remonté avec bien
entendu la poste et les maires pour
pourquoi pas mutualiser des ressources
voilà le retourne
très bien plus personne notre question
il y en a déjà beaucoup c'est le
Président je remercie d'ailleurs mes
collègues de la variété voilà des sujets
qui sont abordés dans dans cette seconde
partie d'audition monsieur le Président
merci madame la Présidente cette variété
c'est le reflet de la diversification du
groupe dans la réalité vous le voyez
bien je pense qu'il y a 40 ans on aurait
parlé lettres et services financiers de
la Poste même pas Banque Postale donc le
tournant il vient aussi à travers votre
questionnement et j'ai entendu vos
remarques justifiées sur des problèmes
de qualité de service je vais je vais y
revenir je vais peut-être commencer par
les départements d'outre-mer où je veux
remercier le Parlement d'avoir apporté
la solution à notre problème car en
passant devant la commission des
affaires économiques de l'Assemblée
nationale avant le vote de la loi de
finances nous sommes vus reprocher de
de prélever des frais d'une part et
surtout d'exiger le paiement de la TVA
ou de l'octroi de mer en dessous d'un
certain seuil et je m'étais permis de
répondre aux législateur changer le
seuil et on prélève vraiment c'est ce
que vous avez fait donc ça va nous
simplifier la vie premier point et je le
redire ce que nous faisions c'est ce que
vous nous aviez demandé de faire vous
nous aviez chargé de dédouaner prélever
les frais on a des douanées on a prélevé
les frais après que les gens trouvent
que c'est cher peut-être mais on a
appliqué la loi
madame la sénatrice on va continuer à
prélever des frais il faut qu'il soit
raisonnable c'est tout mais en ayant un
seul de colis à 450 je crois que ce sera
plus simple et on peut aussi dire que si
quelqu'un règle un colis de 450 euros il
doit lui rester quelques euros pour
payer les frais c'est un peu le
raisonnement qu'on fait quand on est une
entreprise mais nous avons cette
attention particulière au territoire
d'outre-mer ou d'ailleurs nous sommes la
première entreprise en termes de de
nombreux personnes employées et aussi en
termes je pense de soutien aux
collectivités aux collectivités locales
si
si je viens sur CMA CGM et l'annonce que
nous avons fait Rodolphe Sade et
moi-même la semaine dernière en fait les
choses sont assez simples le groupe
cmacgm est en train de devenir un acteur
mondial de la logistique il est
maintenant devenu le premier logisticien
français ce que nous étions auparavant
en France nous restons concurrents ils
ont Colis Privé et nous avons colissimo
chronopost et DPD et c'est la
concurrence normale à l'international le
groupe CMA CGM a décidé de s'appuyer en
matière de dernier kilomètre sur notre
expertise de Géopost c'est à dire
lorsqu'il a des flux de colis ou qu'il a
des clients qui cherchent une solution
de dernier km le groupe CMA CGM peut il
n'y a pas d'obligation peut s'appuyer
sur notre propre livraison
dans l'équilibre du partenariat
nous-mêmes nous pouvons nous appuyer sur
sa logistique
d'acheminement et donc c'est un accord
entre deux grands groupes français
compétition en France et coopération à
l'international avec pour nous le
savoir-faire du dernier kilomètre sur
lequel Rodolphe s'éva logistique et
cmacgm vont s'appuyer je pense que c'est
un accord
gagnant-gagnant dans une compétition
mondiale qui je veux vous le dire
n'a pas baissé d'intensité et notre
premier client est toujours notre
premier concurrent vous avez été
plusieurs à parler d'Amazon on y
reviendra peut-être
sur la hausse des frais madame la
sénatrice je dois dire que il n'y aura
pas d'augmentation des commissions de la
Banque Postale au cours de l'année 2023
pas du tout elle est déjà la moins chère
elle ne va pas augmenter ses frais ça
nous coûte extrêmement cher et le
gouvernement a bien fait ce qu'il vous a
indiqué il a engagé avec les banques une
négociation sur les frais de succession
évidemment quand on les banquier
d'ailleurs plus globalement quand on est
une entreprise on n'aime pas les frais
gratuits vous voyez comment dire bah oui
donc
c'est sans doute ça qui va aider le
gouvernement à négocier il y a une
proposition de loi de votre parc qui
propose que soit gratuit je pense qu'on
l'a compris et maintenant négocie mais
il y a une bien une discussion entre le
gouvernement et la Fédération des des
banques françaises sur sur les horaires
et l'accessibilité vous avez raison et
c'est d'ailleurs l'engagement pour la
raison pour laquelle on vient de prendre
cet engagement avec la MF
qui est nous considérons que la
fermeture inopinée est un vrai problème
on veut le traiter et on veut vous
produire des résultats avons-nous dit à
l'AMF et ça nous engage et on va
simplifier les horaires il y a
aujourd'hui sur la totalité du
territoire 900 formes d’air pour les
bureaux de poste vous voyez donc on va
essayer territoire par et territoire de
trouver une solution et pour nous c'est
un point majeur
j'ajoute qu'on mesure la qualité de
service et que il y a une note Google
pour les bureaux de poste comme pour
tous les services et que cette note
Google je dois l'avouer étant forte
progression depuis plusieurs années en
tout cas on fait très attention à ça sur
les dépôts dans bureau de poste là aussi
on a écouté les élus les élus c'était
150 euros c'est passé à 350 euros dans
le contrat avec la MF précédent là ça
passe à 500 euros pourquoi on fait pas
plus haut mais parce que la Banque de
France souhaite que pour des raisons de
lutte contre le blanchiment de dans le
terreau du terrorisme on augmente pas
ses plafonds enfin sur les dabs et le
sénateur Cardon posait aussi la question
tout à l'heure on est très attentif à la
question des dabs on fait un véritable
effort pour conserver les dabs vous
voyez bien que comme le risque c'est que
les autres s'en aille pour qu'on reste
il faut jouer ça subtilement quand même
et quand il y a déjà un DAB dans un
village mais en général on n'essaye pas
d'en ouvrir un deuxième mais en tout
état de cause on considère que c'est un
sujet important et on cherche à le gérer
partout sur le territoire sur la
Commission européenne et
nos missions
la Commission européenne nous a donné un
feu vert sur tout
toutes les trois missions pressent
aménagement du territoire et
accessibilité bancaire ce qui est une
très bonne nouvelle ça veut dire qu'elle
dit que les missions de service public
sont légitimes et là ensuite une phrase
bruxelloise mais que vous allez tous
comprendre elle ajoute qu'elles ne sont
pas surcompensées ces missions parce que
s'il y avait une surcompensation il y
aurait une aide d'État je me permets
juste de souligner mais vos petits
sourires en quoi le monde que nous en
sommes assez loin pour l'instant il y a
une mission sur lequel elle nous a pas
répondu
précisément c'est la mission de service
universel postal parce qu'elle a besoin
de temps mais elle nous a quand même
autorisé à le percevoir de l'État à
travers la loi de finances ce qui veut
dire qu'il n'est pas impossible que nous
ayons à feu vert parce que sinon voilà
mais je vais pas m'engager à la place de
la Commission européenne la discussion
se passe bien et on a même pu parler
avec eux de l'idée peut-être un jour de
d'une mission d'intérêt général ou de
service public sur l'exclusion numérique
et sur le vieillissement de la
population on n'a pas voilà on a dit si
les pouvoirs publics le Parlement le
gouvernement allait dans ce sens là la
poste serait prête à le prendre j'ai eu
beaucoup de critiques sur les colis en
piteux état et donc je peux pas dire
autre chose que je vous présente mes
excuses quand ça vous est arrivé le
niveau de qualité moyen qu'on mesure et
plutôt en hausse on vous donnera
l'évolution de la NPS mais toute façon
le score de qualité n'a aucun sens quand
c'est son colis qui est en mauvais état
peu importe les scores de qualité
simplement là où il y avait 80 millions
de colis il y a 20 ans en France il y en
a 500 millions donc les sources de les
sources de désagréments sont plus
nombreux sur la signalisation madame la
sénatrice vous avez raison là il faut
qu'on soit beaucoup plus précis il faut
qu'on dise c'est le bureau de poste ou
c'est le point de contact combien y
a-t-il de points de contact à la fin
2022 17013
17000 non mais ça baisse pour une raison
non mais je vais vous dire ça baisse
parce qu'il y a des commerces qui font
faillite ou qui ferment et donc quand un
commerce qui est le RPC dans un petit
village parce que pour qui est un RPC il
faut qu'il y a un petit village fait
faillite bah il nous faut le temps avec
le maire de trouver une autre solution
je veux le redire et je pense que vous
le savez et c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle à mon avis David Lisnard André
Laignel et la MF ont signé le contrat
avec nous la Poste ne cherche pas une
façon habile de filer à l'anglaise dans
les territoires nous voulons rester dans
les territoires mais nous voulons y
rester de manière durable et équilibrée
pour que le groupe soit pas chamboulé
par ça mais on veut rester dans les
territoires on veut rester parce que
c'est la mission de la loi que vous nous
avez donnée parce que c'est notre
mission d'entreprise et puis parce que
c'est là que vive les posters et les
postiers et donc l'enjeu c'est de garder
des emplois dans les territoires ça ça
dépend de nous ça dépend aussi des et de
l'ensemble des territoires alors sur la
sur la répartition madame la sénatrice
il y a en gros 7000 bureaux de poste
7000 APC et 3000 commerces et ce que
nous avons obtenu avec le contrat avec
l'AMF c'est qu'on va gérer ça ensemble
par exemple dans un village et j'ai pas
peur de parler de cet exemple parce que
je l'ai en tête c'est en Gironde et le
nom du village n'a pas d'importance il
fait à peu près 1000 habitants la mairie
est fermée le samedi mais au cœur du
bourg il y a un café
primeur presse et barre et dépôt de pain
où tout le monde passe je pense qu'il
faut qu'on aille discuter avec le maire
pour savoir s'il voudrait pas mieux
trouver une autre solution vous voyez et
c'est ça qu'on introduit grâce à ce
contrat le fait de gérer ça évidemment
il faut tout mutualiser ça me paraît
clair sur la suppression des emplois du
facteur vous voyez bien que toute la
stratégie madame la sénatrice de la
poste c'est de s'arrêter le plus souvent
possible de nourrir les tournées de
facteurs et donc on se bat contre le
temps et l'attrition de de la lettre
c'est toute la stratégie du groupe on
cherche pas à s'en aller et votre
département pardon le dire mais je vais
en tirer bénéfice si je veux dire et un
département très très figurateur avec le
conseil départemental de la Lozère on a
un accord où les facteurs viennent le
matin chercher les repas dans les
hôpitaux qui sont financés par le
Département pour faire la distribution
dans le rural c'est un excellent exemple
de ce qu'on pourrait faire il faut
multiplier ça par 102 c'est ça le sujet
vous voyez on a un bon accord mais il
faut le multiplier par 102 c'est c'est
la complexité sur la décarbonation vous
avez été plusieurs à poser la question
je suis absolument désolé d'en être là
mais on est les leaders de la
décarbonation on est à ma grande
surprise toujours la première flotte de
voiture électrique en Europe toujours
les autres nous ont toujours pas à taper
quand est-ce qu'on sera à 100 % là pour
le coup il faut regarder les concurrents
parce que si les concurrents ne nous
rattrapent pas alors il faut pas aller
trop vite parce que c'est beaucoup plus
cher et vous le savez nous avons
beaucoup avancé dans la logistique
urbaine avec les métropoles toutes les
métropoles Paris Grenoble Nice Lyon et
là on cherche à attirer les flux vers
nous en décarbonant en tout état de
cause la poste et l'entreprise
logistique dans le monde la plus avancée
et la mieux notée en matière de
décarbonation
donc on est très en avance là-dessus on
a l'intention de rester après il faut
que nous continuions à piloter le X pour
cent avec le coup que ça en fonction de
la concurrence et ça c'est du pilotage
d'entreprise pardonnez même ce président
cette question
interstitielle vous êtes prêts pour les
aider feux oui bien sûr on est prêt pour
les aider feux mais notre expérience
c'est que c'est très compliqué pour le
maire
et on en est conscient parce que dès
2014 on a lancé la logistique urbaine
j'ai d'ailleurs pas la première fois que
je vous en parle et on voit bien que les
mers et c'est quelle que soit leur
tonalité politique on le même sujet avec
les commerçants et tout le tissu
économique donc c'est difficile on le
voit nous on cherche vraiment à arranger
le maire et à faire au mieux en tout cas
s'il veut si une mère ou un maire veut
décarboner la totalité de sa logistique
la poste peut le faire elle ne pouvait
pas le faire il y a 10 ans aujourd'hui
on a un circuit du froid on a des
pondérés on est capable de tout
transporter en décarbonée ça c'est un
travail technologique majeur qu'on a
fait alors j'avais la question qui a été
la première qui m'a été posée sur sur le
timbre rouge monsieur le sénateur
évidemment le totem républicain je le
connais et
approcher le totem républicain même pour
un patron de la c'est toujours difficile
simplement quand le totem n'est plus
utilisé et bien l'entreprise doit dire
que elle doit prendre la décision et la
réalité c'est que le timbre rouge n'est
plus utilisé et qu'il était en train de
disparaître sur la compétitivité on
s'efforce d'être très très compétitive
vous savez aussi qu'on a une entreprise
de livraison dans l'Eure qui s'appelle
Stuart qui nous pose d'ailleurs des
traits pas peur parler les problèmes qui
nous posent des vrais problèmes de
management social et donc Chronopost
c'est du j plus un j'ai noté que vous
n'en étiez pas content son président va
le savoir la compétition avec Amazon
elle est particulièrement rude de temps
en temps il nous donne les flux de temps
en temps il ne les donne pas ils n'ont
aucun salarié Amazon à inutile que la
sous-traitance nous on a un modèle mixte
mais eux ils n'utilisent que la
sous-traitance
enfin sur
si jamais vous étiez un éditeur de
presse qui est de la science-fiction
effectivement sur le sénateur
j'ai dit et je m'en suis excusé auprès
de la présidence que j'ai dit moi-même
que les journaux on pouvait pas tous les
livrer avant 12h je sais vous dire
statistiquement combien on en a livré ça
dépend de la longueur de la tournée la
fin de tournée est livrée après 13h même
j'ai pas peur de le dire parce que comme
on fait pas une tournée spéciale dans le
rural et en montagne pour le journal et
bien on arrive à l'écart au-dessus de
sorat dans l'Ariège où je suis allé où
il y a un facteur guichet je pense que
quand la factrice parce que c'est une
fatigue décroche et revient mais il doit
être 13h45 mais comme personne d'autre
n'est passé à ce moment-là c'est la
seule solution je sais pas faire
autrement vous voyez et je l'assume et
il faut pas exagérer je enfin
pour avoir une discussion très fréquente
avec le Syndicat de la presse
quotidienne nationale et régionale il
n'y a pas les mêmes chiffres de mauvais
service mais on fait très attention à ça
je crois que c'est important sur
l'identité nationale et les Français de
l'étranger
le problème madame la sénatrice c'est
les US Nexus alors qu'est-ce que c'est
ça
ça c'est que dès lors que vous traitez
avec quelqu'un qui est citoyen américain
qui a un lien avec les États-Unis il
importe dans sa relation avec vous
l'extraterritorialité américaine a trop
à cause de ce concept de Nexus et alors
nous on est très réticent à ça parce que
ça emporte des pouvoirs de
l'administration américaine sur la
Banque Postale qu'on ne souhaite pas
développer c'est la raison pour laquelle
on est on se sent engagé par l'idée de
fournir l'identité numérique je suis pas
sûr qu'on arrivera à tenir le calendrier
de 2023 voilà je vous le dis très
directement par contre chaque fois que
vous législateur vous préconisez l'usage
de l'identité numérique vous nous aidez
à la répandre sur les territoires et
vous aider les Françaises et les
Français à se protéger l'exemple du
conte personnel de formation et de ses
fraudes montrent bien que sans
l'identité numérique on y serait pas
arrivé et donc nous on est preneur d'un
dispositif par exemple à l'italienne en
Italie c'est la Poste qui est chargée de
diffuser l'identité numérique il y en a
23 millions
si nous en étions chargés nous pourrions
aller beaucoup plus loin évidemment elle
n'est pas chargée gratuitement de
diffuser l'identité numérique parce que
voilà il faut compenser il faut
compenser les choses sur les sur les
zones
frontalières madame la sénatrice c'est
un énorme problème pour le très grand
recruteur et employeur que nous sommes
c'est le Haut-Rhin c'est le pays de Gex
je peux même partager parce que c'est
toujours important ça la réalité le fait
que la tournée 25
de la PPDC de Gex elle a connu très
titulaire dans l'année Patrick chaise le
sait très titulaire il y a eu 13
facteurs dans l'année on mettait un
facteur en place pouf il partait en
Suisse alors comment on fait il y a une
prime spécifique mais le maniement des
primes quand vous employez 200000
personnes est un art subtil d'accord
parce que où s'arrête le canton de Gex
où s'arrête la zone frontalière de
Luxembourg où s'arrête la zone
frontalière de balle voyez donc il y a
une prime et puis surtout nous avons
fait notamment avec Yannick Humbert
beaucoup d'efforts du côté du logement
nous pensons que le logement notamment
pour les jeunes et un élément
fondamental de de rétention de rétention
du personnel mais on est comme vous on
est coincé moi je pense vraiment que le
logement le sujet majeur et nous
cherchons à stimuler Action Logement
pour avoir plus de logements pour les
factrices et les facteurs parce que nous
en sommes le premier contributeur je me
permets de le dire devant le législateur
la première entrée entreprise
contributrice de tout le système Action
Logement c'est nous alors vous devriez
aller plus monsieur le Président moi je
suis comment dire discipliné mais là je
vous fais passer un message nous ne
sommes pas contents et je l'ai dit aux
dirigeants d'Action Logement on a des
salariés et il faut les aider à se loger
dans les zones tendues sur le circuit
court c'est une sénateur on essaie d'ici
développer on essaye de s'appuyer sur
des commerçants locaux et évidemment ce
dialogue entre les APC la poste et la
gestion de la transformation c'est tout
l'objet du contrat qui vient d'être
signé on a un intérêt à mutualiser
ensemble maison France service on en a
400 sur 2600 et nous on est preneur du
plus de maisons de France service
possible avec un raisonnement simple
maisons front de service ça veut dire
plus de fréquentation plus de
fréquentation ça veut dire la stabilité
du bureau de poste donc je vais vous le
redire monsieur le sénateur nous on est
preneur de ça la flotte à hydrogène on y
travaille et ça ne vous étonnera pas il
y a une expérimentation à
Lons-le-Saunier c'est pas le si loin de
chez vous et où les véhicules sont les
véhicules à hydrogène simplement le coût
d'un véhicule à hydrogène même à l'oncle
Saunier c'est celui d'une Maserati tout
est compensé c'est le cas c'est
extrêmement cher tout est compensé par
l'Union européenne donc on a quand même
besoin que économiquement ça tienne la
route mais si vous voulez voir un
véhicule jaune fonctionné à hydrogène ça
existe à Lons-le-Saunier et on est dans
tous les projets pour essayer de le
développer enfin j'ai noté me
semble-t-il chez vous tous
la question sur sur la qualité de
service je me félicite aussi dans le
dans le Var de ce qu'on fait sur la
cartographie
départementale avec avec le département
et les élus vous le voyez bien vous êtes
responsable des territoires nous on veut
rester dans les territoires et on veut
se développer dans les territoires
simplement le constat qu'on doit
partager avec vous c'est que ça ne se
fera pas autour de la lettre ça va se
faire à travers le e-commerce ça va se
faire à travers le colis ça va se faire
à travers la logistique on est en train
de gagner des appels d'offres du
logistique pour nos facteurs ça va se
faire à travers les services et ça ça va
se discuter territoire par territoire
ceux qui en fait la complexité par
rapport aux politiques publiques d'avant
où ont décidé on déploie ça ça on est le
faire mais là aujourd'hui il faut le
discuter territoire par territoire
j'essaie de voir ce que je j'ai oublié
[Musique]